okay here is a really positive voicemail
I was able to the voicemail number by
the way is two one nine two david p a
caller notified me that i was able to
disabuse him of being sucked into the
anti sjw sort of fascistic rabbit hole
on the internet take a listen to this
really good news hi David
I am somebody who has been on the Left
virtually my entire teenage years and
early adult life but about a year and a
half ago I started to fall into the anti
sjw community and from there I sort of
started going to this community that's
like offensively libertarian but sort of
like sports with fascism and that sort
of stuff and I started watching videos
from people like ben shapiro and steven
crowder
and dave rubin and it was getting very
very bad but very recently in the past
like three or four months i started
watching their videos and finding the
channel and it has been a big help and
sort of do you radicalized at me and
putting me back on the left and i feel
much stronger about it than it was
before so um yeah i just wanted to say
thank you and hopefully this gives you
hope that some people do change their
mind
so keep up the great work David take
care absolutely fantastic this is
genuinely good news we have successfully
deprogrammed somebody who got sucked
into this online I don't know even what
to call it always but I think we all
kind of know this red pilled whatever
phrases they like to use on the internet
very very good news we've got a great
bonus show for you today I hope you'll
join me you can get access to the bonus
show as a member or as a patron thanks
to everybody who has signed up over the
last several months
visit david pakman.com slash deals for
exclusive deals from our sponsors for
david pakman show viewers and listeners